こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
新チャンネルを作るといって
早1ヶ月が経とうとしております。
いろいろ準備をしてきたわけなんですけども
今回 その 新 チャンネル の
新しいメン バーの一人を
紹介しようと思い ます
こちら です
はい、というわけで新メンバーのだいちぃです
だ)こんにちはー
既視感がありますね
はい というわけで新メンバーのだいち君なんですけど、
実はですね
もうどれくらい？二年くらい
だ)2 年半
２年半か
2 年半ぐらいですね、実 は
僕と一緒に動画を作ってきたのは彼なんです
裏方としてずっとこう編集とかカメラマン と か
色々実は裏方として手伝ってくれてたのが彼なんですけども
まぁ ちょっと 新チャンネルを機に
何 かあったじゃない映る時が
だいちくんが映るときがあったけど
モザイク処理とか
だ)ああ～いつもそうなってたね
あれがめんどくさいので出ることに なりました
そんな理由？
後自己紹介しないと。
だ)みなさん こんにちは
痛っ！！！
新メンバーのだいちぃです。えっと 年齢は
はじめくんとアー///
年齢ははじめ君 と 同じ
1993 年 生まれ の 25 歳 です 同い年 です
でまた、あれだよね。誕生日も。
は)そう同じ 2 月なんです。
年齢 がとっても 近いのでございます。
だ)はい
他いうことありません
ちょっと情報が少ないんですけども
本当に何 か今 までここまでやってきたのは
彼の裏の支えがあったからだということが
とてもでかいんで
どんな性格なの？
でも 変な人だよね
うーんサイコパス。
変わっ てる 方 な ん で
今後 とも よろしく お 願い 致します
でここで新チャンネル の
いつスタートするのっていう話 が ある ん です けど
あの正式な日にちが決まりました
新 チャンネル は
5 月の２日スタートでございます！！
意図してつくりましたね。これは
だ)そうですね
ゴールデン ウィーク の前日の夜
完璧 な タイミング で ござい ます
まだ ちょっと 準備 期間 いろいろ
パラパラとしてるわけなんですけども
お楽しみにということでございます
(っ'ヮ'c)ｸｴｴｪｪｪｪｪｴｴｴｴｴｴ！！！！！ｺｹｴｯｰｰｰｰ！！！！！ｺｯｺｯｺｯｺｯｺｹｴェエエエエエエエ！！